I love that you have a podcast because
you have a very perceptive mind
I've always enjoyed talking to you are
you trying to probe what's really going
on under the surface of the people
you're discussing and you find that
you're very good at it I would think you
would be this podcast I do on a platform
called luminary that requires that
people subscribe to it what I do on
there is I talk to people that has a
kind of areas of expertise and advance
knowledge and I try to convert it into
language that anybody would understand
now you've already bellowed directly as
a camera that I need to be less esoteric
and you've also threatened to call the
police but why do genuinely trying to
investigate the possibility of
organizing systems in a different way
talking to astrophysicists political
professors philosophers and my hope
Coenen is it that it's somewhat humorous
and accessible to all that's the point
of under the skin I would like to have
you on the show if you would deign to be
on it I would like to investigate you I
would like to understand you just for
our viewers right now could you give me
just a thumbnail sketch of what's
happening with Conan O'Brien through the
laser light glare of Russell Brand
you are a puckish figure and whilst you
present yourself as accessible and warm
you have a deep sense of comic mischief
which can lead to destruction
I would sense possibly in your home life
I imagine your wife detest you I think
you're probably only one mole base to
drink away from wreaking havoc on you
and you on yourself your family
trickster is to be destructive and it's
like thank God that the profession of
talk-show host was invented because what
would you do just talk about that
monorail episode of The Simpsons for the
rest of your life like you'd bring down
the government
you'd be a dangerous man there's a seam
of radicalism in you and I'd be
interested investigating that I also
know you're very warm-hearted and very
beautiful and compassionate and real so
I'd probably explore that in the last 10
minutes the nail on the head yes
especially they're not only the wife but
the children as well there is a loathing
just beneath the surface we're
quarantined together it's no coincidence
that when I walk into a room they walk
out of the room and quickly dude what do
we do I mean at least you probably had a
family at normal age